[Music]
ride through the city like BR I'm on a
mission to get it ride through the city
like BR if you ain't please don't and
now
Brandon six
boy
sh whoa we're live what is popping
family it is 900 a.m. on the dot it is
Monday morning January 29th it is good
to be back in studio although we didn't
miss last week I only miss fire and the
kid and uh golden hour so yeah so we
didn't miss anything last week with the
shop show but good to see you guys um
how we want to do this um yeah back in
studio I had a health scare with the
baby girl if you guys saw my social
media she went for emergency surgery um
she has trouble breathing and she's been
in and out of the hospital like I
explained on my uh Instagram post so so
yeah she had to have emergency surgery
so uh it kind of put a halt to
everything going on uh family first
there and um she's doing all right she
has a fight ahead of her but she's doing
all right and she is a little fighter so
uh God willing I think she's going to be
okay but yeah it's been it's been tough
at the Sha household 2024 has been
kicking me in the nuts it's way it goes
um just how it goes man that's life so
things happen and it's out of you
control but I want you guys to know like
all the support online I see it I see it
and you know I have a weird relationship
with uh social media and that
stuff you know a lot of negativity uh
not just with me but with anyone um John
anic has talked about it we'll get into
that I'm sure but um just part of the
game um so you know I lost lost all
faith in social media years ago but uh
the amount of support I got got with my
daughter in the surgery it's given me
more hope so um I realized
that you know for me I see it on the
ground so I'll meet people and the and
they go oh you get a lot of hate yep no
doubt I get a ton of hate um I get a ton
of love too but the people that do
support me aren't the loudest on the
internet um but they came out for my
baby girl and um you know so I deal with
real life interactions on the street um
events stuff like that on tour
so you know that those those good people
are out there and they came out and
droves um even people that hate me came
out in droves to show support so it
means a lot um you know from erel hanani
we've had our issues I love the guy love
his show best in the game he reached out
Conor McGregor um list goes on and on
but I I felt the love and it definitely
helped at that time and that toughest
time in my life straight up up so
um again baby girl's home now You Can
Tell She's Happ be home not be harassed
by doctors and uh onward and upwards I
guess you know you just got
to hope for the best leave it up to
doctors and there's it just as a parent
you feel hopeless there's literally
nothing can do it's out of my skill set
that's for damn sure so you don't want
to Google the issue your kid has because
you go down a weird road so
you know the the doctors at Children's
Hospital are the best of the best that's
one of the best parts about living in La
when it comes to hospital care there's
there's nowhere better yeah our politics
suck yeah our taxes suck but if you have
a sick child or a sick loved one you
want to be in La so that's the benefit
of living here in the weather outside
that it's tough outside that it's tough
but again to wrap this all up thank you
guys I do see it I love you guys thanks
for the support and uh
yeah let's start the show man let's
start the fre a bunch of people
bombarded me on my everything comments
Tech everything about support for you so
yeah you so much love Yeah tons tons so
I appreciate you guys appreciate you
guys um yeah I had to cancel Austin and
Nashville uh and usually I hate doing
that stuff um it happens but
uh yeah I think this time I just don't
care that's where I'm at I I got I got
to be home more I'm a pull back from
touring so much and I just got to be
home man I got to I can't miss tiger
games can't miss my bosty growing up uh
baby girl uh just I can't do it anymore
I'm tired man I'm tired I'm freaking
tired you know I've been hustling for
over 12 years now not that I'm going to
stop doing the pods but as far as the
the plane life and stuff like that I got
I got to chill out I can do spots in La
I can do local SoCal nor Cal but going
International or you know going across
the the freaking United States ain't
happening right now so I'm going to take
a break from that and just focus on
family and uh do my thing
man do my thing so yeah let's get into
it enough of that enough of that um as
far as fight news go slow slower week
again you got some big UFC's coming up
big pay-per-views you had won
Championship over the weekend our boy
Sage nor
northcut had to pull out huh yeah and
then freaking John liner within an
hour's notice filled in but he got
choked out hour's notice a yeah you can
get Nikki holson dude yeah you're right
told you I hated that for dud it was bad
I was like D do what he's GNA stand with
him it was for two rounds good luck into
the third Gary tonin uh did his thing
love Gary and then our boy super leak
that was insane highlights our boy Cade
Ruto doing the damn thing
yeah that was a fun card that's really
the only thing going on this weekend
obviously a lot of fight news especially
when it comes to the UFC big one Kayla
Harrison signing with the
UFC um fighting on UFC 300 against Holly
Holm I saw there's some backlash
um it seems like any fight Dana
announces for 300 isn't good enough for
the F everyone's up no matter what it is
I don't know what people are expecting
this card is stacked dude um you know I
maybe they're expecting another title
fight which we'll get and we'll get to
that it's probably going to be Connor
but um Kayla Harrison Holly Hol is a
fantastic fight the story Line's
ridiculous as well so they have them
what on the prelims hold on let me I
mean Holly holus Kayla Harrison on the
prelims this on Wiki so let me go to
actual UFC they're gonna be on the
prelims okay it's going to be tough for
them to make the main card but that's a
phenomenal fight uh whay and Yan I'm not
crazy about it I get I get the backlash
with that Justin gaty Max Holloway take
my money even though I'm not I'm a big
Max fans so I'm not crazy about his
chances Olivera uh t uh arm yep Yuri
raki that's fun Calvin Kar Sterling Bo
nickel figorito Cody
garbrandt uh Yousef and Diego Lopez
phenomenal fight phenomenal Jess onra
Marina Rodriguez that was just announced
to you yeah okay I see why people are
upset hey hey after I get it hey now
that I go through the C I know I don't
like it I don't like it now that I'm
going through it man that's shitty
card at first I was like I don't you
know just I don't get all the backlash I
KCK this thing up I'm going through like
oh I don't like this thing oh it's a
solid card but for 300 what are we doing
what are we
doing Yousef Diego Lopez probably the
best fight on that freaking card yeah
that card
sucks it doesn't suck it's just like you
know it do the match nothing but there's
no fight on that entire card that is I'm
like oh I I've got to see this like
there's no fight on there I'm like Oh my
like UFC 100 200 you know you're like oh
my God like that thing would you're like
this is musty TV this don't get I'll
definitely watch it probably do a fight
caign for it
but if I had to if like my son had a
baseball game I'm not I'm not missing
his baseball game for this card as it
stands now no but UFC 100 200 I would
miss some baseball games you this UFC
300 but it's not done yet it's only
there's only one more fight to go maybe
two from what I hear there could be two
in two title fights but um cuz they're
going to outdo 100 200 but four title
fights on it but um I think you get
Connor I do think that you get Connor
that whole thing that where he you know
was at the restaurant drinking
and at middleweight I was like this
never seemed right and the UFC never
officially uh co-signed that so I think
you do get Conor Michael Chandler and
then um I think you get some sort of
middleweight fight on
there what I'm just laughing that's it
yeah cuz I I I think with something's up
with Hamza I don't know why it's the
it's the elephant in the room nobody
wants to talk about not in this room but
in the UFC war room I hate how they call
the war room but there there the
elephant in the room is something's
going on with him where he can't come to
the states I don't know if it's if it's
his relationship with that chian leader
uh you know Kad yeah yeah whatever his
name is I don't know if it's that but
there's something going on there where
he fights once a
year it doesn't make sense but then when
they're in when we're in lockdowns and
they're fighting over there in uh where
is it
Dubai was it Dubai Orab Abu it was Abu
Dhabi when they're fighting Abu Dhabi
this dude fought four times in like
three days and then now that it's opened
up he fights once a
year and then he's like Dana guarantee
me a title shot I think Dan's like yeah
dude if you can come here there's
something going on there it doesn't make
any sense none of it makes sense with
him he should be way more active and
he's asking for title shot cool take my
money I'd watch that they announced
Hamza DDP cool take my I'd love that
fight something's going on with Hamza I
don't know what it is I wish you'd come
out and say it but it it's the waters
over there are murky the waters are
super murky I know that on the Anakin
floring podcast uh the manager of who
was
it uh drus I think yeah the manager
drias was on there and saying like dz'
team made sure to to contact style
Bender team to see if he would be ready
to fight for 300 so that's why they
would call him out so they called him
out because of that because he said that
uh sty Bender team said that they would
be ready for 300 that's why they called
him out so I don't know if that's legit
or not but yeah and no even if Tom I
think the hardcores we'd like to see
Hamza there's argument which I don't ham
would be amazing dude that would be so
much agree Hamza would be amazing now if
the knock on Izzy is he doesn't deserve
it right everyone says he doesn't
deserve it I don't cosign with that in
any aspect cuz that his body of work
overall as a career resume destroyed
hamza's had one fight at
middleweight you can't beat a blown up
welterweight and then demand a title
shot and expect that it H has to happen
like he has some work to do can he be
champ absolutely is there is he as scary
as he was say a year ago no not no not
in any facet I think he has his hands
full with some those guys but um if the
argument based off who deserves it you
can't say hamzat deserves it over izy of
course not you know you say you could
say Strickland deserv it more than any
of them he has a win over is he you know
and I thought he won the last fight I
still do rounds one three and five you
want to debate it bring it
on so um I think Strickland has a
argument as good as anyone you know
so yeah so back to 300 you're going to
get one or two title fights minimum one
on there I think two I think you get
Connor and you get a middleweight fight
whether it's DDP Izzy DDP I something's
going on with Hamot so I wouldn't Bank
on that but back to how we started on
300 Holly Holm Kayla Harrison is a
phenomenal fight ridiculous fight um
Kayla Harrison for those of you not
familiar with if you're watching this
you probably are but for whatever reason
if this reaches outside this fan base
Kayla Harrison is the greatest judoka to
ever compete so you guys know how big of
Ronda was Destroy Ronda was a bronze
medal winner Ronda ridiculous at Judo
she's a two-time Olympic gold
medalist man or woman she's the greatest
us Olympian as far as Judo goes then
comes over what six years ago into MMA
she's a face of pfl for how long face of
pfl um this is why this fight's
interesting to me she had an interview
probably six years ago with Ariel and he
goes you know what about 135 she goes
you would have to cut off both my legs
for me to make 135 we years ago we had
Kayla Harrison on food truck Diaries
she's a mini Brock Lesnar she's Jack
dude she's a big thick girl there's a
picture of her in uh Dustin por they're
about similar size she's a big girl not
fat none of that stuff just a big human
being like muscle not not flimsy muscle
so a cut to 35 for her is is the fight
that's the fight can't she do it can't
she make 135 that's the fight you know
that's the fight and she's a pretty big
favor favorite
um you know as a betting man the only
reason it's not a bad idea put some
money on Holly Holm as such a big dog
because the cup for Kayla Harrison is
going to destroy her is she going to do
it absolutely absolutely the people
doubting her that are that don't think
she can make the weight you don't
realize the the accomplishments she has
as an athlete being a two-time gold
medalist that's more impressive than
being a UFC champion that's more that's
harder to do than make it to the MLB and
NBA to be a two-time Olympic gold
medalist is so freaking hard is so rare
so her mindset is completely different
than anybody she's ever faced she is an
absolute Savage she will make 135
guarantee
it what that looks like when she gets in
there I don't know and I will stand by I
think Holly Hol is the toughest matchup
fighting the pfl she's just murking
girls Peko beat her
okay but she's not facing UFC
competition night after night that's the
difference you might have one or two
people in the pfl can make in the UFC
but the what makes the UFC so damn
challenging in the the the NFL of mixed
martial arts is the level of competition
night after night after for from
fighting from 1 to 60 is a nightmare to
in order to get to that top 15 you got
to go through murderers Road everybody's
good there's no walks in the park
everybody's good pfl there's some
cupcakes it's just it's just they don't
have the roster so there's some cupcakes
so Kayla Haron yes p is a monster and
yes Holly home is I think 42 cool the
level that Holly home has been competing
at is so much higher than any other
opponent she's ever fought and she's
going to be depleted at
135 um Holly Holm is world class Striker
I think it's by far her toughest
competition so there's so many
storylines in this fight which is why I
love it it's also a tip of the Hat you
know she's she was the face of pfl just
like Chandler was the face of Bellator
the UFC rips him over and then go what's
what we do with her they oh she was your
star you guys took her pretty far watch
this cuz she wins this fight her next
fight she's probably fighting for a
title then defending the belt that's if
she can make 135 three times she has to
make it not only once not only twice
probably three
times it's going to be quick too because
she's not a young chicken this going to
be quick so it's hard to cut weight
especially at the age especially for a
female cutting that much weight is way
more difficult for them so the fight in
this is how does she look look at the
age of 33 cutting a significant amount
of weight I think the lightest she's
ever competed at
is 47 I think she made
147 it's tough dude uh Dana did say
though on record that uh I don't know
how much this is like legit but he said
she's done some pre-cuts and it looks
pretty good at 135 oh that's not true is
it nobody's cut to 135 for the hell of
it that's not true but it makes us feel
better you know makes you feel better
makes you feel better she's so jacked
man when you introduced me to her at
Mala Studios like she was just so mini
Brock not like again there's girls like
I can see how they can I'm like how are
you going to do it again six years ago
when she was even lighter than she is
now she was like you'd have to cut off
both legs and make 35 now she has to do
it so she's removing both legs breaking
news she's GNA compete with no
legs um that's the fight her her fight
is against her making 135 and then not
being completely depleted and perform
against Holly Hol who's been in the
biggest fights so um that's I see I I
like this fight better than gatei
Holloway I don't like the hallway fight
I don't I love Max hallway I ju the 55
just isn't a place for him it's there's
too much damage I don't want to see him
get hurt I love Max H love Justin gatei
I don't like the
fight I'm more the Kayla Harrison versus
Holly Hol then any other females on the
card those other female fights whatever
this dude insane K hon make one [__]
135 this also shows you that the 145
division's gone yeah because if the UFC
wanted to revamp that they would just
have her as the face of it
nope and if she does beat Hol home I
don't know who's going to beat her now I
bet you nunz comes back that's a super
fight you get I bet you get a super
fight with Nunes by the end of the year
with Kayla Harrison and Amanda Nunes I
bet that gets her back I love how
everyone's like she's avoiding cyborg oh
my God hey two-time gold
medalist you think she gives a
flying about cyborg no dude has nothing
to do with
that nothing to do with that and people
always say that cyborg she's not the one
that actually does the Post no her
husband her boyfriend is yeah he's the
one that talks all that mess she's
awesome I remember great great human
being what do you got Jen oh first let's
go to a break real quick if you don't
mind O'Reilly oh oh
O'Reilly Auto Parts how long has it been
since you change your spark plugs
replacing your spark plugs can restore
efficiency and performance to your
vehicle right right now O'Reilly Auto
Parts get a $12 O'Reilly gift card after
rebate when you purchase four or more
select AC aridium spark plugs maintain
your performance and fuel mileage with
new spark plugs from O'Reilly Auto Parks
I lived at O'Reilly two weeks ago my
lightning were're putting a Whipple
supercharger kit on it it didn't come
with all the parts so I had to go to
O'Reilly the parts weren't on the show
floor but the customer service they
looked it up they had the parts in the
back ready to go I have to wait I fre
love O'Reilly all right you can also
improve your visibility with new wiper
blades right now save 12 bucks on a pair
of rainx rugged XL wiper blades plus get
two times of reward points and extra-
large profile and premium features make
rugged XL blades the right choice for
extreme weather driving durability the
professional Parts people will even
install your new wiper blades for free
Brian Callen for spark plugs to wiper
blades and more save now with doit right
deals in store at O'Reilly Auto Parts or
O'Reilly auto.com
all right right after that
Progressive oh man just two things I'm
dealing with auto parts and insurance
insurance is a beast I'm waiting to post
my video of my TRX until I get my
insurance most of you listening right
now are probably multitasking yep while
you're listening to me talk to you
you're probably also driving cleaning
exercise or maybe even grocery shopping
but if you're not in some kind of moving
vehicle there's something else you could
be doing right now get an auto quote
from Progressive Insurance it's easy you
could save money by doing it right from
your phone drivers who save by switching
to Progressive save nearly $750 on
average and auto customers qualify for
an average of seven discounts discounts
for having multiple vehicles on your
policy being a homeowner and so much
more so just like your favorite podcast
Progressive will be with you 247 365
days a year so you're protected no
matter what multitask right now quote
your car insurance at progressive.com to
join over 28 million drivers who trust
Progressive Progressive Casualty
Insurance company and Affiliates
national average 12- month savings of
$744 by new customer surveyed who saved
with Progressive between June 2022 May
2023 potential savings will vary
discounts not available in all states
and situations
Progressive conance a beast huh they
take their sweet time I want my truck
back yes so we I think we talked about
this off air okay just
let me know for a fact so shinoki had to
fight uh he was supposed to fight Sage
northcut yeah and then Sage northcut had
to like bounce out last minute like an
hour before the fight cuz he he couldn't
have his coaches there for some reason
with some Visa issues weird yeah so John
liner who's super dangerous stepped up
within an hour's notice got choked out
in about three minutes yeah first round
saved the fight though but got choked
out yeah yeah but that was super cool an
hour's notice the Nikki Holton I mean we
talked about the top show you called it
man like H oh that would be too tough
terrible idea yeah so he TKO they should
rematch in the first two rounds are
grappling for that'd be great yeah that'
be that'd be great and Cade Rolo one of
the R Brothers of course
wins Al righty let's
go so John anik made headlines recently
because he said something about like MMA
fans which we've heard for so long right
MMA fans are some of the worst
it's never been worse than the most hate
right uh right now it's never been worse
yeah so it's a multip there's there's
layers to it I it's become political
right so with Strickland obviously his
fan base is very right and then a lot of
the MMA outlets and media members and
some people in MMA are left so the
politics have leaked into mixed martial
arts which whenever things get political
and leaks into sports it's never good
you look at the NFL when the BLM stuff
was going on they're refusing to take a
knee for the national what are we doing
just play football what the hell is
going on so you don't want that stuff to
leak into sports unfortunately it's
leaked in to mixed martial arts really
just the UFC it's leaked into the UFC so
when John anik you know says stuff uh
about dupes and Strickland or anyone
yeah H really really it's the Strickland
stuff so that fan base comes for you
that that fan base will come for you
it's very toxic it's never been worse
than right now because now it's just the
way social media is there sides either
you like this guy or you hate him and
the ones who hate him are be way louder
than the ones who like him trust me I
know I talked to anic talked to an about
it yeah I I love this podcast I always
listen to it but anex the best I told
him I said dude what you're doing is
you're succumbing to the minority
majority people absolutely love you
you're making a decision based off the
minority now the minority is very very
loud they have nothing better to do they
want to be loud on social media
99.99% of people that you walk by
absolutely adore you you're going make a
decision to leave the game based off the
minority he's like you're right bro I'm
like you're talking to a guy who deals
with a ton of hate for doing free
podcast and standup so trust me nobody
gets it more than me you can't let the
minority
win they're loud they're annoying but
that people love John anic but sometimes
if you're not you think that's the
narrative oh everybody hates me oh this
this no they're just loud dude they're
loud
idiots yeah he can't walk away no dude
if he walked away that would suck so bad
dude he won't he's just going through it
yeah said emotional state at that time
and it it it get to get you going so
what he does though like you I know you
sto reading comments and stuff but John
I do now oh you do now yeah I'm back
running all my stuff now well there you
go that's my lesson but John said like a
lot of people are like unattainable but
he wants wants to be the guy that kind
of like talks to the fans and stuff but
then you better have if you're going to
do that especially right after a fight
cuz remember especially in America after
that fight ends the majority of
Americans are on Strickland's side so if
you say something against Strickland
they're going to come for you dude so
you just got to realize what you're
dealing with so he issued this I didn't
think he needed to do this I didn't
think so either but I get it too cuz I I
know he loves the MMA fans so he wanted
to you know put something out there so l
but last week on my podcast I was
heightened emotional state following my
allegations of bias at usfc 297 I made
some regrettable comments relating to
MMA fan base while I was surprised at
the extent to which my comments were
repurposed and uh sensationalized I need
to be more responsible on the open
microphone so much work goes into the
execution of just one UFC pay-per-view
so it can be tough when my Integrity on
the broadcast is called into question
it's what you sign up for Johnny that
doesn't excuse my retort I am just a
fiery passionate flawed empathetic guy
and sometimes my emotions lead the dance
to those that many fans who who I've
offended probably the ones who support
I'm like whoa whoa whoa dude the
majority people love you what are we
doing here I'm sorry that was not my
intention for 12 years I pride myself on
being accessible at the fan base that
will continue I've learned a lot over
the last 48 hours on to Anaheim I don't
even know if you need to issue an AP
apologize for watch joh Being Human
everyone you you know sometimes I'd like
to come on and rant about the hate I get
but it's like um you just got to keep on
keeping on dude it's just everyone gets
it I don't give a [__] who you are man I
mean the bigger you get the more you get
it too it's just part of the
game posted this afterwards what I'd say
to John an calling M fans the lowest
common
denominator these people are are the are
way these people are the way you have a
are
a weird wording here strick them
whatever these people are way you have a
paycheck and you make way more than most
maybe the NFL is better choice for you
than MMA also you guys are a bunch of
savage cutees I'm here for
it that's just Strickland being strick
okay so now that we're on Strickland so
he was super cordial to DDP after the
fight uh and I have another article
after this but he says here a like after
he had his stitches done he said he had
a a headbutt that yeah we cause him to
not see yeah yeah and even uh John anck
even said like oh sorry I didn't you
know we didn't see it on the broadcast
comments let me see go down goes regret
that we didn't isolate nor see that on
the broadcast incredible fight and
performance not hard to see why your fan
base is enormous yeah yeah that's John
hey dude
hey like you said the wrong tag to
somebody it's mean you come back in the
room
hey my man my man yeah but so big dog
big
dog so shrien said this which kind of I
don't like but you know whatever because
I didn't take the card's way out and
tell the doctor I couldn't see and got a
no contest the only reason why he took a
round from me is because I couldn't see
I won that fight the world knows I won
that fight the belt they gave you will
never make you a champion Joy they had
to stitch through muscle to get it
closed thank you everyone for your
support has really kept my head up
throughout all this grateful I I stick
by I think you won the fight yeah well
me and you disagree on that one too you
think you pleas won some guys do I
thought it was so close just being Luke
Thomas think you won not a big deal CH
Sona thinks like drus won all five
rounds which I think is crazy but well
Cha's doing it for ra you can never take
what cha says I don't know he did a
talko bell review the other day you know
it's like I have no idea what he's gonna
say me and Rogan think Strickland won
yeah and by the way Thomas you guys are
more professional at this game than I am
it was freaking close it was close but I
just don't see you don't have how you
don't give Strickland three rounds I I
rewatch them like I rounds so you got
135 those are the unified rules and I
always watch it as like an actual fight
like a real fight like the whole thing
so I'm not watching it the the proper
way oh no to judge it yeah so a people
who say that like if this was Pride all
right it's not what the hell you talking
about they might as well be swimming in
water and fighting those are the same
rules they don't exist B people go you
got to take from the champ like Brian K
no that's stupid I think that's that's
not a that you might as well say
Bigfoot's real there's that's not a
thing in professional sports that's not
a thing that's like saying that's like
saying uh uh who Inon the Super Bowl at
Chiefs well 49ers need to beat them by
21 to really beat them instead of
beating him by if they' been by one well
you got to Beat the Champ what no those
aren't the rules that's an old school
yeah it's such an old way of thinking
it's not but it's not even real in
boxing that's not a rule people made
that rule up there's no rule setting in
any sanctioning body that has that in
place that's not a thing just so
everybody knows well you got to take it
from the champ that's not
real yeah and if it is real you would
have gave it to Strickland because he
didn't take it from him so even by your
weird rule set that then Strickland
still won but that's not that's just so
everybody knows that's not a real thing
in any capacity in any Fight League ever
that's not a real thing that's something
people made up it's a it's a urban
legend well you got to take it from the
champ no no no you you could beat them
by this much it's a that fight's no
different than the first prelim fight
the way they score they're all the same
no matter who you are not a
thing yeah I mean so dce said I chatt to
him afterwards but then I saw his tweet
saying that I understand calling for a
rematch in the sense that you get back
get the public behind saying oh you know
you didn't win the fight he came to me
in the cage I think this is the first
time publicly publicly I'm saying this K
me in the cage right before they
announced me as the new Champion I went
to him I shook his hand I said you're a
warrior well done was a great fight he
said no you definitely beat me he said
to me you deserve it you won that fight
you beat me I said I also think so after
GW with you on that yeah after I won the
fight you could see on his face he knew
when the ref had our hands he knew he
wasn't winning that fight then of course
he talks about the headbutt which is not
true it is true we just saw it on video
um I remember the exact punch I caught
him with that caused a bleeding that's
not true here's the thing though I don't
care what Strickland said inside that
cage when you're in the middle of a [__]
fight with your underwear figh another
grown man in steel cage you don't really
know those that fight so you don't
strick is probably like man think I lost
that fight because he's been especially
coming from izy fight where he dominate
before that dominate before that
dominated then gets knocked out by Alex
P so he's used to dominating this is a
close fight probably didn't go in his
head how he thought he's like yeah I
probably lost that fight that doesn't
mean
[__] because when you rewatch it I BET's
like I won that fight I won the first
third and fifth what are we doing
dominate the fifth won the first for
sure and then you got to give me the
third so it's okay for a guy to go I
thought I lost that fight and they
rewatch it like oh [__] I I won that
fight how did they score it the other
way so him saying ah Sean said to me in
the cage I won the fight that doesn't
mean
much just like him saying no I didn't
headbutt him you did but again it's no
knock on him inside that octagon he he
probably he didn't mean to it's not like
he lunged in with his head he's coming
up and headbutt him you don't you not
remember that same way Shawn didn't know
he won the fight and there also was a
punch that landed that kind of cut I
think it cut open as well but then yeah
there was like a thing where his head
the headbutts what did the most damage
for sure where you can't see out of his
eye but again it's not Naka dupes he
didn't know he's just fighting yeah it's
a fight
so uh this was super cool to see um D
sues going back to South Africa in the
airport he had a huge like welcoming
I'll play just a little bit of it but
yeah that's cool good for him he
deserves it
man that's insane that's
insane now just imagine the retion get
if he's the real
champ I'm just kidding I love DDP things
happen it's a fight game [__] happens
you know if Strickland you know wanted
the Bell he shouldn't left it you know
in the judge's hands that it's [__]
happens um okay so apparently Errol
posted this um Andy Foster from the
California State athletic commission
he's trying to get rid of the or just
trying to make more sense of the whole
grounded opponent thing right and yeah
it's like a gray area it's super gray
and I don't even when I read this it's
still confusing to me so the current the
current language kneeing or kick in the
head of a grounded opponent a grounded
fighter is defined as anything other
than the souls of the feet bearing
weight mhm and the proposed language
this is what he wants to do uh a fighter
shall be considered grounded and unable
to be legal need or kick to the head
when any part of their body besides
their hands or feet comes in contact
with the canvas so it's
like so so so if you're on all fours you
can still get kicked to the Head okay so
if you're on your back yeah if you're on
your back or you know if you're on your
stomach side CU they don't want like a
you know guy to get half guard and doing
some stupid like finger touch or
whatever yeah yeah well that's that's
pretty cool so if it does come to effect
it'll be later this year yeah no doubt I
hope that works out Andy Foster also
sanctioned figh he did it's all money
dude it's all money so um so there's
that in addition to says uh proposing to
abolish the 12 to6 elbow rule cool he
also sanctioned
slap yeah dude
money um let's do this one real quick so
there was rumors that Mike Tyson would
be figh oh
no Fedor a million in boxing in Saudi
Arabia take my money but then so then I
think someone from Mike Tyson's team
said that it was it was just rumors it's
not real but I think it's super possible
that oh yeah it's definitely impossible
I don't think it's happening also
fedor's not going to play that sparring
stuff he's going to try to take your
head off because he's Fedor yeah but i'
I'd watch that all day of course dude
Fedor that'd be sick
dude I think Fedor beats him but yeah in
boxing yeah damn yep he's playing for
keeps quick
break oh man I only recommend products
that I personally use I reached out to
this company to work with us to give you
guys the best creatom on the planet we
talking about happy hippocam this stuff
helps me tackle a busy schedule and get
freaking stuff done it's the best way to
describe it just helps you get stuff
done it's not like an energy drink it
gives you more of a zoned in balanced
good mood feeling whether you're at the
gym podcasting with the kiddos you got
to socialize with dads whatever it is
get you some Crum whatever it is they're
shot
their gummies tablets powders they got
their KPS they got it all so however you
want to get your katum use happy hippo
take out the guest work you don't know
who to trust you can trust happy hippo
all you got to do is go to happy
hippo.com promo code is thick with three
C's 24 you get 20% off for Life use it
as many times as you want for the best
Crea on planet Earth happy hippo.com Pro
code thick
24 oh boy this next one is the elite of
elite supplements listen I've been with
some supplement companies for quite some
time and again I reached out to these
guys to work with me it is hands down I
think they're behind me the hands down
the best supplements on planet Earth it
is third party tested for ban substances
NSF informed Sports certified all right
it cage separates from itself from other
competitors CU it's clean formulas no
colors flavors from artificial sources
all right they're pure caffeine is
organic caffeine instead of synthetic
caffeine um my favorite products is the
m the my what got me hooked on cage is
mindset so it's
a it's a powdered neut Tropic with
caffeine the mindset elad is what I use
I use it every single morning to kick my
day off you will not find a better
product to get your mind right for any
task that you have than mindset I
guarantee you you can feel the
difference if not you're crazy your
mindset is the hands down the best of
the best the Pre-Workout Elite I feel
like I could run through a freaking wall
on their pre-workout the energy the
pumps the focus it's insane proteins
taste incredible it's uh Ultra filtered
100% ISO isolate protein so they got you
covered there they're there for you when
you're ready to train harder live
healthier and become the strongest
version of yourself all you got to do is
go to cage.com use the code shop 20 just
shab SE a for 20% off that's cage k a
ged.com promo code shop for 20% off the
best supplements you've ever put in your
freaking mouth get the mindset go from
there the pre-workouts ridiculous the
protein's great the hydration stuff is
fantastic but again get the mindset
Elite with the caffeine it's a game Cher
that's cage.com prom code shop for 20%
off all right um Tom Aspen said that uh
his team reached out to or no so UFC
reached out to him saying that if he
wants to fight stpa miic and he said yes
300 yeah and stpa declined because he
wants to only fight Jon Jones I'm with
CB has one fight left it's this
legendary fight why would you risk
fighting a young upand Comer Savage and
Tom Asen all doesn't do much for stpe so
Tom tweeted while we're talking about
stpe my manager was contacted by the UFC
asking we'd like to fight him on April
13th I said of course accept it a little
later we're told that Steve Bay doesn't
want to fight me only interested in
fighting Jon Jones on that note I will
stop crying except it ain't going to
happen that's all you can do Tommy enjoy
the fight that me and all the other fans
want to see Legend versus legend for the
heavyweight title maximum respect
yay yeah I guess we're all dying to see
it I don't know anyone who vying for
that fight I mean I'm glad John's didn't
come back but I
think what would like and I know John
was like being Stipe who's known as the
best heavyweight of all time I need that
on my resume I think it would go further
if he beat Tom Asal because Asal is
going to be a future champ he's already
a champ but he's going to carry on get
some huge wins going be tough to beat a
win over him in asal's Prime is to me is
more impressive than a win over a
weathered Stipe Who Walks Like Sylvester
Stallone do you think that happens this
year though John and Stipe probably not
huh doubt it that sucks maybe dece
November December late in the year
depends on John's
rehab but if I'm steep I'm turn it and
Tom down Tom Tom beats both of them hate
to tell you guys no yeah well I agree uh
this is just a quick little picture of
henah FAA who's like the pfl champ and
him standing next to Ryan Bader who's
the Bellator champ and then he just
looks Bader is Big right this guy is
like huge is he really yeah especially
for heavyweight really how tall is he
six foot no freaking way 61
maybe wow okay well he this guy I'd give
him 61 what they have listed on
Wikipedia 62 let me look right now
they's giving an inch on
Wikipedia 6'2 yep he's about 6'1 dude I
thought he was way bigger okay that's
why it's so impressive what he's doing
at
heavyweight well there you go let me see
this star down I
mean he just looks so much bigger he's
huge yeah and he's like a killer too
like mostly tko's Ko's CH all up in the
middle there yeah dud CH does all
different promotions too right like
that's a cool gig yeah he does UFC PS5
yeah UFC just lets them float around
yeah um so Ferguson Tony Ferguson just
announced recently that before the fight
with Patty pimpl he had an MCL
tear that's not good not the way you
want to go in the fight
yeah so I don't know if that showed or
that's the reason why
he didn't win I wonder if he's like
who's going to carry the boat Tony's
like I guess I will I one knee I'll
carry the
boat and he was like training super hard
with David gogins too so I don't know
man but he said something about him
retiring didn't he no he said he would
not retire no I know he's upset when
Dana told me he wants to see him retire
but I don't know why they don't do Tony
versus
Conor Conor fight two legendary fight I
like that for Conor get him back on the
win winning path huge Payday for Tony
exactly that's the best makes all like
Tony vers well not now but well yeah
he's screwed but even if even if uh big
if but if Connor were to beat Chandler
the next fight do Tony get two two wins
in a row then then we're go then we're
going
Sizzler would you guys rather see Conor
McGregor here so if you're in in Casey
you're the biggest Conor fan in here
besides me bigest me and you are Conor
dick riders would you rather see Connor
Chandler Connor Nate Diaz 3 or Connor
Tony Ferguson I'd go Connor Nate Conor
Tony Chandler yeah I want to see Conor
Nate
three agree yeah I agree with you that I
think Chandler's his toughest fight and
I don't like it for his first fight back
as a Conor fan I would rather i' rather
see Chandler Connor and then uh Ferguson
and then Nate but yeah that's just me
completely opposite huh you want to make
it difficult on our boy huh Jesus
Christ Chandler be great love Chandler I
just don't I just I think it's a very
tough fight for for Conor layoff so it's
a tough fight yeah I want to see him get
a win same I'm not saying Nate's easy
but easier than Chandler Tony's not easy
but easier than
Chandler
yeah um unfortunate news so Tatiana
Suarez she's injured again I don't know
I don't know there's I didn't see what
what it was exactly but McKenzie dur is
replacing her to fight a Manel Emos Dam
at 298 so
yeah to the end of her career man it's
like my 2024 it's just not
good you know it's rough yeah just
kicking right in the
tits man that's tough
tits 2024 kick me right my tits
dude but I mean but she on go back she
said I'm thankful it's not something
that will keep me out for an extended
amount of time all I can do now is focus
on things I can control yeah you just
got to Hope yeah doesn't sound like it's
a neck or anything like that damn dud
just injury I know all that wrestling
catching up with her that's a bummer
dude cuz she beats aandal lios you know
and she's fighting for a title you
always said that she would be she would
be champ but anybody it's turn b nickel
yeah um this is kind of random but um so
Uriah Faber and Sacrament Sacramento
State College or whatever they're F
they're doing the first ever Combat
Sports program right so you know they
have wrestling and stuff like that but
this is actually combats so boxing mu
Tha wrestling all that stuff and uh you
youri faor is like the head guy there
he's going to be coaching it yeah and
then they're also going to like work
sick class to take in college yeah right
man they're going to work in t should I
go back in college man that'd be sick do
some
MMA Combat Sports Martial Arts
University or combat you and then who's
the guy with him he goes some yeah I do
some amateur boxing so I spend a lot of
time in boxing gyms oh tell me you don't
do know how to fight without tell me you
don't know how to fight but I mean euri
Faber is going to be taking control of
it so yeah that' be dope good for him
it's the first time it's ever happened
so that's big hope he catches on
uh this is also a random one karate
combat apparently uh they're going to do
a a thing a kateed combat event in a
backyard of a mansion and Rick Ross is
supposed to be hosting it
interesting I don't think it's Rick
Ross's place but it's just going to be
some sort of mansion somebody's Mansion
yeah that's cool the there's a new
president that came in recently so he's
like a like a influencer kind of guy so
he's he's doing all these kind of like
crazy stuff right now
um oh I saw this you saw this it's
actually pretty damn funny I think he
all right you think he all right okay
well it's good bypass it but yeah so
anyways it's just if anyone wants to
watch it's ma deales his Instagram and
he's talking about he has a point how
guys are keep find stupid to Revenge
their fights he's like I'm going to
Revenge a fight he goes He this guy's
retired but I can get him out of
retirement some guy from old school days
old school yeah Frankie SS or something
like that um I think he has a good point
guys just get to the title shot and keep
calling out yeah yeah guys ranked below
he goes what the f is this yeah yeah
that was
good all right
dude so just this weekend's
fights yeah you get a fight night not
going to blow your hair back Apex at the
Apex so 8 or 6 PM
PST you got Roman fighting
imav R moo Drew Dober that's a fun one
Randy Brown
Muslim
yeah meatballs fighting God she's
falling off huh we'll see after they
gave her such tough fights like you're
bad Jiu-Jitsu here's three black belts
in a row she's like arm bar armar arm
bar get out of here go get fish and
chips the did are dirty man oh you
struggle with jiujitsu say less here's
all black belts they're going to rip
your arms off yeah not a great fight
night but it is what it is it is what it
is is that it brother hey did you see
the Roadhouse trailer oh I did Conor
looked dude awesome Oscar that's what I
said Oscar award winner we were both
saying it like I was so shocked that he
did that well it was so good I know it's
like he acted just like himself like
dude you know what's crazy it's like
he's Conor mcer yeah but in a movie they
said they said he looks Jack he looks
awesome he looks so cool yeah I love it
dude dude it was so good I was so
shocked they're like we want you to
channel that you're in a bar okay and
you're you're wasted probably did some
cocaa and you get in a fight he's all I
can do that they're like really he's
like for sure yeah yeah yeah I can do
that he crushed it and also this might
be a stretch but did you see in the
trailer where he's like telling Jake
Gyllenhaal like I got something to tell
you don't let someone get this close do
you think that was a little bit of a CH
son in reference like I can't let you
get close oh that's
right yeah maybe did you see the thing
that the UFC cut from the
promo someone aired it but it's Jake
Gyllenhaal and he's at the UFC fight oh
yeah like how do you feel he's just
ready it was like so cringey like oh no
that's not how Fighters talk it was so
rough the UFC cut it from the promo
because UFC was like no no no no don't
do that people are gonna hate you for
that but Jake Jal looks great too and
there's some dime in it it looks
freaking good we should all go together
yeah thick boy field trip let's do it
yeah it's going to be on Amazon oh is it
yeah it comes out on Amazon I don't
think he's in the theaters really I'm
pretty sure it comes out on Amazon look
it up though you know Ronda was supposed
to be the original Road House
mhm we could do a companion for it watch
it here at the
studio uh yeah maybe um or it's just
going to be on you're right dude Amazon
Prime Yeah March 21st oh that's a
while I'm I I honestly it's it's way
better than I thought though Connor like
was it was actually making me want to
watch no he was born for this it he has
so much money but if he wanted an acting
career especially in like if you think
like Jason Stan movies oh guy Richie
stuff easy all guy Richie all day guy
Richie's foaming at the mouth to sign
Connor to whatever movie yeah Conor you
know he has the personality to do it if
you want to be WWE you think Logan's
good have Conor do it I mean he'd Crush
for sure Crush in
WWE I've had a rough 2024 but no one's
had it more rough than Vince big
man right he just resigned right yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you can't be
defecating on people you know I didn't
see all the details but I saw some yeah
I've seen two conflicting reports like I
saw the thing that the woman came out
and said and then her text got released
it it's one those things so that's why
now one those things it's one of those
things you got to look really into it
like really research V McMahon 65 with
giant tits dude he was on all the
steroids like of course you
know well that's it
kids uh yeah that's it happy Monday
January 29th thank you guys for tuning
in like subscribe do all your thing got
a bunch of dope Toontown uh content
coming out the TRX Fiasco uh the
Lightnings finally be done I got a photo
shoot for Street Truck magazine on
Friday the demons getting done by borla
we got a lot going on in Toontown so all
right kids uh again thank you guys so
much about my daughter I see it I love
you guys thank you for the support
finally um that's it love you guys till
next time I'm
out